pour à vous merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france depuis plus d'une
semaine
à chaque jour sa nouvelle polémique et
son lot de tensions est ce que les deux
parties se dirige réellement vers un
odile je crois qu'il faut comprendre
qu'on est dans la dernière ligne droite
avant un accord ou alors pas d'accord
l'impression que j'ai très sérieusement
aujourd'hui c'est que barry johnson
quelque part joue la carte d'un accord
c'est sam éléments qui me paraît le plus
marquant un accord pourquoi parce que
pour qu'il y à un accord négocié et
accepté par les deux parties
il faudrait que d'ici la fin du mois les
deux parties s'accordent sur les
questions essentielles sur lequel il ya
actuellement ils ne sont pas d'accord
moi je parle il ya la question de la
pêche mais aussi cette question qui est
revenue sur le devant de la scène qui
est ce projet de loi que mme johnson a
présenté et qui remet complètement en
cause la crédibilité même de l'accord
donc on est dans une phase de vérité
donc comme dans chaque négociation
c'est un peu la carte on joue à se faire
peur chacun les uns les autres en se
disant il y à bien une des parties qui
va céder mais n'est pas sûre que ce soit
cette fois j
l'union européenne qui cède c'est ça le
problème est que pouvez-vous nous dire
sur ce fameux projet de loi que le
gouvernement britannique a présenté le 9
septembre parlement qui contredit en
partie l'accord déjà signé encadrant
donc cette sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne
le projet de loi en question c'est un
projet de loi qui remet en cause
l'accord sur l'irlande du nord
actuellement dans l'accord de sortie il
y a eu une espèce d'accord des deux
parties pour que les contrôles se fasse
naturellement en dehors des frontières
physiques c'est-à-dire que les produits
qui sont à l'intérieur de la grande
bretagne puisse circuler librement mais
que les paires d'huile et les produits
qui circulent au travers de l'irlande du
nord par exemple pour distribuer être
distribués sur la république d'irlande
que cela puisse être contrôlée et
continu a finalement payé les taxes
nécessaire et donc ce que le projet de
loi debré johnson introduit c'est
finalement remettre en cause cette
liberté de circulation
une certaine manière est d'une certaine
manière
rétablissement des frontières donc c'est
un non respect de la parole donnée qui
pose un véritable problème de
crédibilité ça veut dire que finalement
les britanniques ne respecte pas un
accord qu'ils ont signés et qui a été
ratifiée je le rappel par le parlement
britannique et donc on est vraiment dans
une période assez difficile
il n'est pas sûr que bon il jonnson soit
en mesure véritablement de faire
admettre même si l'actuelle majorité qui
lui pose pas de problème il ya quand
même un certain nombre de figures de sa
propre majorité de l'o2 conservatrice
qui eux ne sont pas du tout d'accord
pour s'engager sur une voie dans
laquelle c'est la parole même de la
grande bretagne qui a remis en cause
alors justement boris johnson qui accuse
l'union européenne de préparer un blocus
en irlande du nord
l'union européenne qui se dit furieuse
que faut-il en penser
tout accord international mais tout
accord qu'elle quechua est basée sur la
confiance
dès le moment où cette confiance n'est
pas acceptée effectivement tout est
possible mais lorsqu'on regarde bien les
termes de l'accord des moments où chacun
cherche à jouer véritablement la carte
en toute bonne foi il n'y a aucune
raison qui est véritablement de problème
sur cette question de l'irlande du nord
donc je pense que nous arrivons
finalement à un accord
peut-être sans problème mais encore une
fois
tel que c'est parti et nous avons encore
quelques spaihts juste quelques semaines
qui nous reste est bien là chances d'un
accord est de plus en plus évidente mais
comment vous analysé la situation est ce
qu'il ya une chance de voir finalement
les britanniques faire marche arrière
sur ce fameux breakes site
c'est toujours la question dans toute
négociation on joue encore une fois je
le répète à se faire peur donc on pousse
les cartes plus loin possible ce qui est
ce qui a changé un petit peu dans cette
affaire c'est que finalement les
britanniques l'un finalement remis en
cause leur propre parole est donc cette
remise en cause de leur propre propre
parole pour un véritable problème de
crédibilité
est ce que on peut faire confiance aux
britanniques
ou est-ce qu'on peut pas faire confiance
aux britanniques
donc aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans
une situation un petit peu dramatique il
faut voir de quelle manière finalement
les européens qui restent très unis en
la matière on l'a constaté
les deux négociateurs même s'ils restent
sur leurs positions savent très bien que
l'union européenne c'est-à-dire des
vingt-sept et avant ne bougeront pas sur
leurs positions alors qui va bouger
c'est ça la véritable question il s'agit
cent pour terminer de la crédibilité
justement international du royaume uni
dans quelle mesure est ce que les
britanniques le prennent en compte
moi je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ça
c'est la véritable question c'est aussi
la question de la personnalité même de
boris johnson qui est un personnage un
petit peu particulier qui est prêt
finalement adopté des positions
iconoclastes en matière de relations
internationales
est ce que boris johnson peut être
crédité dans son propre pays
c'est pas évident il faudra voir de
quelle manière la négociation puisse se
rétablir d'une certaine manière avec
quand même comme base de négociation le
fait de se parler de s'écouter
mais je précise quand même une chose les
les points qui restent encore très
différents à discuter sont innombrables
et sont extrêmement difficiles
je ne prends qu'un seul exemple celui de
la pêche parce que si effectivement il
n'y a pas d'accord et bien c'est tous
les pêcheurs français qui est
actuellement pêche dans les eaux
britanniques qui seront privés de pêche
il sera plus loin ça veut dire qu'un
accord aurait une conséquence même sur
la sécurité en irlande
puisqu'un accord finalement aboutir et
d'une certaine manière à rétablir a
amené l'obligation on établir une
frontière entre les deux irlande et ça
personne n'en veut merci à vous françois
poulet mathis rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des institutions
européennes